So, we know that,
in order to avoid collision,
we should have a longer hash value.
Now, the question is, how many bits
should we have in a hash value so that
it is not feasible to find two different
messages that have the same hash value?
Suppose the hash value has L bits.
Then, there are 2 to the L,
that many possible hash values.
According to the birthday paradox we
can think about we have 2 to the L,
that many possible birthdays, therefore
if we have a square root of 2 to the L,
that is two to the L divided by two,
that many messages.
Then there's 50% chance that two of
them will have the same hash value.
In other words,
the attacker only needs to search 2 to
the power L divided by 2, that the many
messages, in order to find collision.
Therefore, if L is 64,
which means the hash value has 64 bits.
Then there are 2 to 64, that many
possible different hash values,
This means that the attacker only
needs to search 2 to the 32,
that many different messages,
in order to find a collision, and
this is quite feasible with
today's computing power.
Therefore, we need the hash
value to be longer than 64 bit.
Therefore, in hash functions,
the hash value is at least 128 bits.